america's longest war is over the
pentagon says the last u.s troops have
flown out of afghanistan after a 20-year
mission the departure comes after two
weeks of chaotic and desperate scenes in
and around kabul airport as thousands of
foreign nationals and afghan citizens
tried to flee the taliban have now taken
control of the airport and proclaimed
afghanistan's full independence
there's no doubt who's in control here
taliban fighters parade their win on the
tarmac of kabul's international airport
some even taking selfies from the
cockpit of an abandoned aircraft
first of all i would like to say that
afghanistan is finally in every sense
free and independent
and our forces are controlling the
military and civilian parts of the
airport
normal activity of the airport will be
started very soon
close by military aircraft
some apparently disabled in the rush by
american troops to get out of
afghanistan
as fast as possible
just hours earlier the commander of the
82nd airborne division became the last
u.s service member to leave
that prompted celebratory gunfire at the
airport to mark the ending of this
bitter 20-year war
alhamdulillah thank god that we took our
country's independence
all muslims and all afghanistan people
are happy and share the happiness with
us
taliban soldiers may be enjoying their
victory
but the chaos of the last desperate days
here is left plain for all to see
long queues continue to build up outside
kabul's banks
and there isn't a woman in sight
the taliban is expected to form a
government within the next few days
a chastened international community says
it's hopeful it won't be as extreme as
feared
but on the ground it's clear
who
holds the power
let's get an update on the situation in
kabul we can speak to journalist franz
marty now
france american troops have now fully
left the country after 20 years
what are things like in kabul today with
the taliban fully in control
i was briefly in the city center today
and there there wasn't much of a
difference to the past days so shops
were open people were going about their
business there were maybe a little bit
fewer people on the street uh certainly
fewer women but there were still women
around
um there is still like the taliban
haven't imposed like new rules or
something like that uh
most of it
continues as before
the atmosphere wasn't jubilant so
if one wouldn't have known that this
historic
moment happened the night before one
wouldn't have seen it
some shopkeepers told me that business
has broken down
and that they're worried about the
future
one street vendor also told me that he's
worried what what will come now
so it is still that like most afghans
seem to be wary about what the future
brings yeah a lot of uncertainty friends
we saw the pictures of the taliban now
fully in control of the airport as well
so what about foreign nationals and
afghans who want to leave the country
can they still do so
the taliban have several times assured
that foreign nationals and afghans with
the right travel papers are allowed to
depart the country
so far before it was because of the
evacuation operation the the airport was
like
as only operated by these evocation
flights and very restricted to get
inside now the civilian airport might
open sooner than like uh people might
have expected uh the taliban have
certainly interest and there are reports
that they get like support from qatar or
turkey uh to um again reopen the airport
how difficult it then will be for
foreigners or afghan nationals to leave
remains to be seen foreign nationals
probably no big issue
because the taliban don't have an
interest to hold them there afghans is
another story but one should also keep
in mind that the taliban probably also
don't want to have afghans here that
might begin to resist their rule so like
if some afghans want to leave the
taliban might not put that great
obstacles into their way
france what can we expect from the
taliban now will they be able to form a
government
the taliban minority factor in power
they have since they entered kabul um
conducted like talks with uh several
politicians that haven't fled the
country
reiterated that they want to have an
inclusive government but at the end of
the day their attitude is the attitude
of victors so they might include certain
figures in a government but uh at the
end they decide what will happen
um and and who will rule and how and
given that they have during the past 20
years always said
that the the constitution that was in
place the system that was in place
wasn't islamic or not islamic enough um
one can expect that there will be
radical changes and that they will
announce the government and try to
implement this and given that they
managed to topple the government they
certainly have the power to implement um
several things
journalist france marti reporting there
from kabul thank you very much for that
update
well let's get some analysis on
america's withdrawal now we can speak to
liz shulker she's a u.s political
analyst here in berlin
welcome to the show the u.s has
essentially now said that it is
withdrawn without getting all of its
people out
how big of a problem is that
the problem really depends on who you
are as secretary blinken said the number
of american civilians left in
afghanistan is in the low hundreds
however we have left thousands of our
afghan allies behind and although i love
to hear it's optimistic that they might
be allowed to leave the taliban have
lists and they have already as deutsche
bahnow's been going and trying to find
some of these folks and so i think it is
a big problem that america uh kind of
didn't live up to its promise to bring
its allies back with them well secretary
blinken has said this is the start of a
new diplomatic phase with afghanistan
what could that new phase look like
as we saw
ambassador ross was one of the absolute
last people to lead the country on the
absolute last flight out i worked at the
state department i know how passionate
um the civil servants there are about
the mission and about the country and so
they have tried to reiterate that this
mission is not over they're going to uh
have an embassy uh hopefully in in work
together uh with afghanistan and with
the taliban in qatar and i think uh
hopefully we'll see strength and
diplomatic ties kind of moving forward
there are a lot of people who have been
referring to this withdrawal as a
failure of the west but also of course
of the u.s as well how much you think
this has
damaged the us's credibility with its
allies
i don't think this is the first instance
this war has damaged credibility for
america i think this is rightfully a
wake-up call for america and the role
that it plays in the world both how
america sees itself as well as what the
world expects uh
the u.s can't come in with military
might and do nation building and instead
has to go back to those diplomatic
missions that we talked about and
hopefully the dedication of these civil
servants and the moving diplomatic um uh
actions will restore some of that
credibility and yet we saw this
extremely chaotic withdrawal in the last
phase and of course the horrific
suicide bombings at the airport that
killed us marines as well so what do you
think the fallout will be for president
biden
that's a really serious question i think
looking uh forward we have the midterms
coming up now congress people and
senators in their home states and their
home districts can kind of uh spin this
and present it in their own way there is
some distance between biden and uh
individuals in their districts but i
think biden needs to really move forward
um with strength and and talk about the
hundred and fourteen thousand people uh
that we have safely evacuated from the
country as well as really the progress
um diplomatically that we can see in the
next six months but it's absolutely
something that will hammer him moving
forward and he needs to remain
accountable for
u.s policy analyst liz shulker with us
thank you very much